and today's January 6th and in
Washington today President Biden will
Mark The Assault on the capitol
occurring just exactly two years ago
he's going to honor some of the police
officers who fought with rioters that
day federal prosecutors of course have
charged more than 950 people and a
congressional panel investigating the
attack has heard from more than a
thousand Witnesses all detailing what
happened that day and as Scott McFarland
reports criminal trials continue but
some staffers are also still coping with
trauma yeah
go go as an angry mob climbed walls at
the Capitol
smashed Windows pushed back police
and threatened to hang the sitting vice
president Congressional staffer Sharon
Nichols was alone barricaded inside an
office worried about losing her life it
was frightening it was terrifying being
alone was the hardest part
very few rioters were arrested that day
the police were vastly outnumbered and
at times overpowered by the mob
but the FBI seized records from more
than 5 000 cell phones and amassed
thousands of hours of video of what may
be the most documented crime in U.S
history charging at least 950 people so
far nearly half of whom have either
pleaded guilty or been convicted at
trial including Oath Keepers founder
Stuart Rhodes convicted of seditious
conspiracy those in favor say aye
aye after an 18-month probe the U.S
House January 6th committee referred
former president Donald Trump to the
justice department for prosecution
alleging he incited an Insurrection
these people are not going to take it
any longer Trump has denied any
wrongdoing but already a declared 2024
presidential candidate a former Federal
prosecutor says if there are any
criminal charges they may come soon you
think if they were going to move on this
they'd want to move well before the next
Presidential election well before not
only that but if there is going to be
charge they want a trial to happen
before the next election as for Nichols
she still works here and started a
support group for other survivors it
helped us to connect with one another to
talk about it to share our experiences
with each other and compare
Capitol Police have suffered a series of
resignations and retirements after the
attack on their officers but they have a
new Chief who says they've made more
than 100 significant improvements in the
time since but he acknowledges there is
more hiring and more work still to be
done Adriana
Scott thank you so much in front of a
beautiful Capital this morning beautiful
but a little chaotic this morning